hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to amnesia
rebirth we just got off the phone with
some doctor and then apparently yasmine
was also there
and we got to go through the desert we
got to get to this town in order to
survive
whether we're going to get there or not
is up to my intelligence
and my ability to see through
[Music]
it useful can't we just get out of here
this place gives me the creeps they're
dead and gone
can't hurt you now ah
jesus jonathan look out
the door get to the door everywhere
well number one you were proved wrong
and number two maybe i shouldn't have
been sketching and maybe i should have
been helping you guys
that's probably fine
why do i need to look at this so
intensely quartermaster only i get it
oh that's a headless body
that's one of them headless bodies
oh is that jonathan is that is that
jonathan how can you tell know him from
his torso
do you all right sure
i've got this lantern but it's oil runs
out super fast
as far as i know actually it just seemed
like that before okay missing supplies
will be treated as
theft little old me
missing supplies it couldn't be there's
saltpeter in there i'm gonna have to
blow some up
sure seems like i might have to blow
something up hey
hey how you doing
maybe i should stay away from the holes
in the walls oh
yeah sure get the millet out of here get
the millet out of here get them in oh
get them
get the millet out get the melon out of
here
what is that hello thank you sorry
goodbye
oh no no no no oh no oh no
so peaceful in between the panic
all right well yeah i hope there was
nothing else that
ah there we go
i think i think it stopped yeah you know
probably for the best hey baby hi
dawn you all right there i'm gonna get
through i'll beat up any monster that
gets in between
me and keeping you safe
yeah i should have turned down the job
definitely yeah oh look there's even
footy prints
look at the footy prints wow they really
went all out with the engine update on
this one i'm quite impressed
um also i'm still not entirely sure
you're not an alien baby considering i
have an alien
bracelet that lets me walk through
portals and whatnot
all right okay baby you just sit tight
baby
don't worry baby i'm gonna take care of
everything baby
it's coming it's
get over here
after it killed jonathan we escaped
through the big gates into the past
uh-huh
through these big gates into that pass
i can't move this not on my own uh maybe
i could i'm pretty strong
okay so what do i gotta do fire a shell
i see a tank oh i see a tank
oh do i need to do what i think i need
to do with that tank
oh that's right in the quartermaster
area there was saltpeter
is that what i'm have to blow up
oh wow
oh please tell me it's so please
tell me it's true please tell me
please tell me that is what i have to do
oh my goodness oh my god oh my goodness
oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh hey hi
[Music]
well sorry about that man that sucks uh
got a key though
[Music]
well this seems oh
my goodness okay wait i need to see
through the hole
okay so we are not lined up
so we probably should it really doesn't
want to
turn that way oh come on
okay uh
oh okay we just got to unlock it first
i see okay are not quite
not quite not quite a little more
man shooting these tanks sure is
complicated why don't they make this
easier almost almost
okay get ready everybody the earth
shattering kaboom is on the way
oh that's pretty good pretty good but we
can do better
what was it squeak was that a door
opening oh locked on tarp
fire fire
fire fire fire oh
no bullet all right need to make
bullet okay no bullet got it
no bullet right
okay so hey you got a bullet you sitting
on one
you're secretly sitting on one lock that
in place so that not going nowhere
it's still lined up yes oh dead center
okay so i gotta go make a bullet or find
a bullet make her find a bullet
find bullet make bullet listen baby
you're about to get experience of fire
in a tank
are you ready for that kind of
destructive responsibility
i bet you is i bet you is why does the
worms creep up on my vision when i look
down on my baby
are they always there are they just
always there
also what are they it's a little strange
whatever hey
[Music]
i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about i i know nothing about the
delicacies of the political
climate here so
that's great
oh thank you all right hey a water pump
excellent it doesn't work what a
useless pump why did i come here
let's go oh hey hey get away i'm gonna
step on you
crunch did work yeah whatever
listen i got some crazy cravings right
now i could eat a scorpion hole
do i gotta go back in i i've got to go
back in don't i i got a key that's right
wait i got a key what is the key tour
a key found in the tank with arsenal
written on the label okay so it's gotta
be
to that soccer club or something i'm
trying to make a sports joke but i don't
know enough to follow through with it so
everyone just nod your head
man i sure am funny um
maybe there's another back wind because
it would be a long way around if i had
to do that
okay this is strange
huh i don't know if i can just go in
here
i can okay good i mean not good if the
monster is literally red on the other
side of this
but you know good enough that it's gonna
save me time from getting from a to b
it's a convenience good enough not
necessarily a survival good enough
i couldn't tell you which one's more
important hey i'm back
hey buds i am back
okay so that's locked up and it
definitely isn't for that one
i'm gonna operate on the assumption that
it's stalking around here somewhere
whatever it is
oh okay how you doing
yep
if you wish to have something issued
from the supply applied to cpi delacroix
do not take them yourself
well i'm gonna take him myself
oh oh he opened it
oh
thank you oh no thank you
you have some creative curses i have not
heard of these
salt peter i have salt peter i've got
peter's salt what do i do with it
that was loud okay so there must be some
other place that's locked up
i don't exactly remember seeing
anything like that did you guys see
anything like that
maybe over there
i guess i would have to get back in
somehow
what was that what happened
is there nothing is it nothing or is it
ever
is it everything ah i knew it
i knew it i knew it i knew it
are you actually a thing or is that just
like a like a one timey hidey hole kind
of thing
all right cool hey
all right cool hey why is this all
blocked up now this wasn't blocked up
before was it
this was not blocked up before was it
okay
then am i not going to be able to get
back
uh crap um
crap crap hey
hi how are you doing okay good that's
fine
carry on okay there's where i
threw that down i don't think i might be
able to climb back up there so it can't
be up here
there must be some kind of uh arsenal
out here right i would have thought it
would have been the quartermasters area
but
i could be entirely wrong
okay all right
[Applause]
i don't like it oh what is this i don't
know
that oh that goes back that's right
okay i'm just go i'm just gonna assume
that um i'm gonna assume
there's nothing here for me i'm gonna
assume there's nothing here for me
if there's nothing here for me then i
don't need to worry about anything then
it's all good
this door is here and it doesn't open to
this
definitely not so where's the arsenal
i mean that looks like a thing
all right whatever i'm headed back
outside i don't exactly know
what specifically one one
one oh no
oh no so we just gotta find an arsenal
of some
kind oh god mike you shut up
shut up shut up a-hole
the weed oh
of course of course
of course probably shouldn't light
matches around all this gun powder or
whatever
this is a gun this is a boom stick
oh my god it's part of a boom stick it's
not a boom stick okay whatever
all right who's laughing at me
why you think this is funny it's not
funny
it's not funny
hi can i help you
shh little one
it was a dream just a dream all of this
was just a dream
nothing to worry about nothing at all
just a dream okay all right let's
uh let's do this ooh coil
seesaw rope de la croix
okay well i did get this salt peter
i probably needed the salt peter to do
something in here so i don't think that
time was wasted
i don't remember this please yeah i
don't either
tell me what that smells like to you
what do you you say it first you tell me
what you think it is and
well i'll see if i agree with it oh
that's a bigot
okay well that's a gunpowder press okay
okay makes powder mix unpredictable
better than nothing ask corporal
khadirith in doubt
i'm about to blow myself and my baby
sky high if i don't get this right i
ordered the saltpeter for tanning not
for your powder
i have moved it up to my stores and
there it stays rexistion your own
well i got the saltpeter i didn't even
know i needed it but i got it do not use
on metal
oil blade after use okay well that's
good
i don't know what this is so it's not
really going to help me
because i don't why is there a trap
there
what trap is that it's a trap it's a
trap there's a trap there
why why is there a trap i don't trust
that trap there's a ballista there
what [ __ ] yeah if i was running in that
would have been bad
oh i probably could have caught the
thing with it
oh oh no
okay i do like the the match mechanics
better than the the tinder boxes from
the other game
i i think i think it's more fitting you
hold a match you like some
lights what you can find oh there was
something there damn it and then uh
maybe i can cook myself some food i'm
ravenous some scorpions out there maybe
i could
you know cook them right up
charcoal sure let's grind up charcoal
thank you we are one of the same we are
two of
soul we get each other oh well that's
weird
oh there's lots of little knickknacks
that you can hide stuff here
man if they open up mod support to this
game i bet people can make some really
crazy stuff they seem to have a lot more
like environmental stuff detail stuff
oh yeah uh-huh what's happened to you
god whoa i didn't even see it i see why
you were panicking now
oh my god
all right painkiller how you doing there
oh careful this is
rigged oh you're right i didn't see that
i would have blown me and my baby sky
high
all right well good yeah glad you're
talking to yourself
all right let's get these candles going
okay
okay okay okay we're good i'm gonna see
if i can get some more
more light please yes yes yes no no no
no no no no no the answer is no okay
all right yes please
the following items are off limits
without authority of the captain
medicine's strong spirits the cage is
not to be opened without a senior
officer present
wait do you want to blow up a senior
officer seems like maybe that was what
you were going for
all right okey dokey any
hidey hole entrances hmm there whatever
you say
just gonna walk past all the whatever
the hell you
call the the decorations it's halloween
yeah
it's gonna walk by the decorations
lovely
they're lovely trust me you know you
don't need to doubt it for a second
these
these decorations you're gonna win
you're gonna win
the halloween contest you're gonna win
it i could jump
i could but i won't
i won't do it oh there's one that's what
i'm looking for
did i put that out or is this hi
hey how you doing what's this way
thank you that was that was easy to miss
but i appreciate it
couldn't stop looking at your handsome
face you know
just really really some special you
anyway you get out of here you're you're
too handsome
i'm tempted to smooch you
all right i'm gonna go now maybe this
isn't such a great idea
maybe you should stop talking to
yourself huh or are you talking to your
baby
listen your baby if i'm your am i your
baby am i your baby talking to you
i'm wise listen to me you gotta listen
it's a heavy door i still like the
interaction things in this game i'm not
sure about but it's fine it's all good
good heavy blanket get out of here close
close
close all right now
i just jump
listen mama let me tell you a thing or
two about a thing or two
you don't know nothing about what is and
is not dangerous
i'm an adrenaline seeking baby i live
life on the edge
priceless artifact destroy
get out of here somebody get this baby
some beer
let's just have a good time medical
supplies yeah medical supplies
ointment of sulfur you know for joints
listen mama this baby wants some
opium give me some loud down
gnome just start slugging it down
let's see poison in excessive quantity
well that would explain why uh
in the last game in the dark descent uh
main character might have been losing it
a little bit but
you know everyone's got to live a little
and when you're being chased by the
demonic entities
from the depths of hell sometimes
god do what you gotta do to who those
who come after us
i have failed we tried to die in
defiance but these devils will not allow
it the screaming does not stop
i cannot shut it out i cannot bear it
they treat my men as cruel child treats
a puppy
reveling in the joy of their pain and
they watch me all the while
alderit keeps crying my name gardener
has stopped breathing he is the lucky
one suicide is a sin but the lord has
deserted us
and i will not give these demons their
satisfaction so here i take my stand and
make my death on my own terms
i pray you do not tell my orally
of this fate tell her we died in some
glorious noble purpose
and that i was a father to be proud of
she has done nothing to deserve this
hurt
scene ado captain augustine lift hill
well i mean seems like your plan might
not have worked there buddy
sorry about that hey dad with a flag in
his hand
that is hella patriotic
anyway can i open
i shouldn't touch it hey yo
okay
maybe i should have just gone the other
way around you know maybe this wasn't
such a good idea
why am i all why am i noodle noodle-eyed
mama why are you panicking so much come
on
i'm a baby that's like the rat and
ratatouille
sorry excuse me i got too close to the
truth
uh all right um is this key
oh well
that's a nice shortcut i guess i could
have gone around the outside but uh
now i don't have to thanks guys
escape artists i got achievement all
right cool
is there something over here i just
noticed this
i literally would not have looked at
this oh weird
oh interesting
hello oh it's just the other way around
okay well that's boring
well that's boring give me my oil
where's my oil
come on okay so what do i mix mix
i don't know what do i do uh sulfur
powder
saltpeter milled charcoal
[Applause]
oh okay
okay oink
okay sulfur powder
oh this is liquid sulfur right okay
so something about this what is this
okay so i gotta turn this
into powder
sulfur ointment okay so there's gotta be
a way to turn sulfur ointment
into powder
boil it boil it
boil boil it take the lid off
and then boil it boil the oil
bubble bobble toil in trouble well it
can't boil off that way
boil boil
that's gonna take a while um
what is this oh this looks fancy this
looks expensive
can i have this i'm a greedy baby hey
mama
listen to me i guess i should just have
a look around
see if there's anything that can happen
help me i'm hungry
i might want to eat some those scorpions
look pretty good maybe just shove those
down your gob
oh this is probably perfect let's just
grab that with my hand it was only
boiling that's fine all right uh
popper in boink
delightful smell and slam it home
instant tank shell
and oh far i still have all my fingers
so far
try it out i guess i guess all right
let's do it
let's blow up a door just try it out
what's the worst that could happen
i'm not strong enough to open the door
so i just
who's that little one kitty cat uh-huh
why is that creepy to anybody else
probably not i'm probably only
creeped out by that
it's like just barely not photorealistic
enough
that it looks super weird to me i don't
know why just
very strange
all right let's load her up uh
put it in the slot here
anywhere oh i'm down i'm up oh
i'll take that all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
what could go wrong three two
ow
yeah what could go wrong what could
possibly have gone wrong
that also looks very strange what is
happening
[Music]
alice little one
something's very wrong something's very
wrong something is wrong here
there's some depends deep or something
or other and i'm not
well that's fine that's probably fine
that's probably fine
yeah totally fine what
the [ __ ] i don't know
yeah get it off me mom get it off
good little one i'm so
strong
am i doing it i have no idea if i'm
actually doing anything
you know i don't know how to tell
[ __ ]
seems like it's all good down here mom
don't worry about a thing
i haven't heard you in there
oh no
oh no oh no
okay i'll just rotate the yeah yeah
i i'll rotate oh no
okay probably fine
perfect
yeah i'm gonna i have a bad feeling
oh no no they wouldn't
oh god i need to get out of
oh here oh
those bastards
look at chills uh they wouldn't
they wouldn't right they
wouldn't they wouldn't right there's
something down there
they wouldn't do that no
in this open apparently not
i'm just getting flashbacks to the water
level from the original amnesia and i'm
just
like
okay if you say so
if you say so if you say though
if you say so if you say so if
you say so if they say so
what do they say so
oh is that do i need to knock hello
i'm trying to drop it can i
clang clang it's not working
the the interaction is just a little
wonky okay
well that ain't working all right um
oh this looks
sure oh that's not good
no no no no anna
[Music]
i'm going i'm going i'm going i'm going
ah where am i i can't see where am i
let's start okay we're fine
oh no oh
no oh
god no mother of
god and all of his angels
oh what what what did i uh which is
where is it what is happening what's my
baby
baby what's going on there
that's what's you i can't feel you
i don't know what home is this is home
to me
it's nice to know you oh well good to
meet you too
all right anyway i'm gonna sleep now or
not
yeah parties tonight need a nap oh
if we are to investigate further then we
will need a
mild uh we will need to build
mild build a scaffold we will need wood
and a good length of rope i think there
is some break
and the walls deep below the water level
used to be much higher and we can see
light shining through
the water
okay sounds good is that two pieces of
paper oh my god it is
oh my god it is i
don't know what any of this is sure it's
i think it's a map of the area but i i
don't know
how to reference anything to what i'm
seeing
okay man sure is dark clang
yeah i'm just sorry i just feel a little
destructive
don't you worry about a thing i'm sure
no one boarded this up
all right mom we got this together
hello okay good it seems like there's
always torches nearby
it's the funny thing i never lit torches
in the original amnesia and i'm lighting
them
all the time now so i think i think
that's good like they got
they got like that balance and matches
do not last long
i think they technically last longer in
real life than they do right now but
hi oh hey whoa what are you doing how do
i do the thing how do i do the thing how
do i
go pokeball uh how do i do that
i don't remember how to how did i
shoot yeah there it is
got that just in time all right
[Laughter]
fair heights playing in hard all right
what was that
yeah whoa yeah yeah whoa okay yep
then i'm not sure i'm gonna be able to
race whatever this is controlling
huh what a what an intricate puzzle
system you've got here
you're glad they really built it through
with safety centers
yeah calm calm like the ocean
calm i'm down calm
aw i am
calm oh am i out of
this thing does not last was big medium
oil
okay that's good enough for now hello
wow
okay i just got it well all right nice
ass
how are you doing hey how you doing nice
ass hey
hey what's up nice ass listen
i know uh i says when i see one actually
i guess i've never seen one in the
world i'm a baby in a womb i've never
seen anything
i have no idea what anything is ever so
shut up and go away
maybe your ass is terrible whatever
i'm not sorry some behind here
oh there was okay there's lots of
secrets tucked behind everything in here
it's just because the the the
environment is actually really really
detailed which is quite impressive
oh please it's darkens i'm out of oh my
god i'm out i'm out
give me more give me fuel give me fire
literally just give me fire
oh no i'm doomed no
please okay it is apparent from the
writings of usm of the intent of the
newcomers
they came to us from a far place with
their thoughts set on conquest
and they made us into their servants
their slaves their prey their fodder the
last word may also be translated as crop
their origins are unclear but it is
highly likely that this was another
incursion from the lands around the nile
or even further into persia okay
the queen had no king many princes came
to court her
but none brought her joy she was sad
because she wanted a child
she asked her wise people to help but
they said why do you want a child we are
all your children
i must have a baby she said because i
cannot be queen forever
and someone must be queen after me
nonsense the wise people
we will brew you a magic potion and then
you will live forever you will always be
our queen
so that is what they did but sometimes
when she was alone the queen cried
because although she was mother to the
world it was not enough
well then that's just greedy or
something i don't know whatever
anyway i don't know i'm not a mom i'm a
ah
i'm wasting oil okay three i'm not gonna
light oh
[ __ ] oh geez
these kicks all right cool thanks
anything in here skiller
yummy anything in here
what do we got well that's it
on that day the people thronged the
byways of the city
when the doors of the tower opened the
name of their new empress
rippled through the crowd before her
like die
into water
she stepped out bare-headed and
bare-handed
dressed in a simple row and she
walked amongst the people some
cried out with joy some wept openly
behind her came to maku and the rest of
the alchemists
bearing a litter on which rested seven
crystal orbs
okay so that's definitely tying in to
the original
uh amnesia way back in the day because
there's something about the orb
something about the orbs and
trans-dimensional yada yadas you know
what i mean
azrael gautier ruling in the southwest
part of the world
and hath 20 great dukes to attend him in
the day and as many a night
who have under them several servants to
attend them did we imagine eight of the
chief do except along to the day and as
many as belong to the night because they
are sufficient for practice
and the first four that belonged to the
day had 40 servants of peace under them
and
so has the first floor to belong to them
in the night and last four of the day
twenty and the last four of the night
ten peace they are all good nations and
willing to obey thee
those that are for the day to be caught
in the day and those of the night in the
night
and these be their names and seals that
follow with here's eight dukes
that belong in the day oladores
carga boonie els rabbis
arisat ariel
tuple maligel
i nailed those names no one can argue
i really did them justice nope
there we go it is the third day i've
fallen in with a group of morris
travelers one of them is suffering
struck with the curse of the king's evil
so i prayed with them for her fortitude
that she might reach
the cave of the mother with all speed
they told me
that is within two days journey
should all go well yet there is an
obstacle still to overcome the path goes
through the dements
of one park henrys a robber baron of the
ottoman people
pilgrims must pay a heavy tithe to use
his water and to travel the mountain
pass i have spice and three
tailors left i pray it will be
sufficient
i don't know what a failure is but it
sounds impressive so i think he
i think that guy made it i think that
guy definitely made it
100 100
oh is it opening or not no okay whatever
you know i didn't want it to open anyway
i don't know what would have been on the
other side of it
let me just let me just real quick
anything else anything else anything
else please one more
yes oh that's a wheel ah scary wheel
you are all terrified of that right not
just me wheel
get put that back in place okay smash
sorry i'm just baby's jumpy
baby's jumpy
spurs splatters
what
well i feel better all right what a fun
time just checking behind everything you
never know what's gonna be
snuck back somewhere thank you
okay well i didn't need to stop baby
please
mom yes
sorry i just i ca i keep yelling i don't
know why i'm just a very loud baby
i think everybody knows this but i am
hungry and there's a lot of bugs around
good eating so you're just wasting there
mom i don't like the blackness of that
the darkness okay
okay yeah i'm close okay
anything else on the walls here is that
a pit
can i like that can i just light this
whole place on fire
oh my god
i don't know what the growth is
i don't know what that's all about
that's a weird okay whatever
great good stuff good stuff i think it
was just a drawer opening but
my goodness they really want to startle
me
oh one set of oil slap
we're there to slap them in okay
i'll do something what do i do what do i
do oh
god oh my god what do i yeah i'll find a
place to hide is this
closet i don't know where am i oh this
man i'm dying
i'm crushing
i know that i'm kind of in the whoa ho
ho ho
it's
is it still a problem
i think it went in a hole so i think i'm
okay
okay we're fine totally fine
100 fine it's okay mama
it's okay hey don't you worry hey don't
you worry hey don't you worry
don't you worry about a thing because if
you start worrying then i'm gonna start
worrying and then it's gonna be a cycle
of worry and that's not gonna help
anybody
i don't like the hole
hurry up hurry oh not now not now not
now not now not now not now
not now not now not now
okay okay
okay this is great all
good here super good
actually the goodest some might say
some have said rumors have said how good
is this situation
oh may not now not now not now baby hey
the darkness it feels like i'm losing
control i'm losing control of what it's
just me you're perfectly normal human
baby
very
i don't know
oh why did i like that it was perfectly
fine right here
oh well might as well keep going light
it light it light it okay yes
all right let's see what was up here
first
oh this game started to get a little
spooky
just a little bit just a little spooky
here and there
a little spookiness ow oh cuz
off this what baby what
yeah it can't be too bad yeah yeah can't
can't be too bad
yeah yeah by the way mom don't worry
about those broken ribs that you had
earlier that you kind of forgot about
that was me it just mended up up here i
saw they were broken so i just went
well there you go put some put some glue
on there and
you're good to go good to go mom i'm
glad i'm here
all right can you actually do a thing oh
is this some kind of a puzzle
oh it's
it's an ancient egyptian
crane fascinating
wow now that's really something
that doesn't go anywhere oh i see oh
wait i see i see i'm seeing
so that's all clogged up by the looks of
it
so what we need to do is we need to go
to the right right about not quite here
yeah right there we're gonna make this
go up
why can't you go up it really looks like
you should be able to go up there
oh well that's not good okay um i'm not
sure
what this is for
that's clogged up okay whatever i'll
come back to this once i figure out what
i
exactly need hello boink hello
can this open please very slowly
thank you thank you very much
um oh that's a good
this is a good sign
i can make that jump
[Music]
you know i don't feel too comfortable
i swear okay sure thing mom yeah you got
it okay that's definitely stuck i
suppose i could jump over to this
and then go over here yes
it seems correct as correct as
should i look should i look
i'm looking i am looking i'm going in
the hole i'm going in
ah i'm going in i'm going in i'm going
in bone good sign good side that's a
good sign
oh no not now it's fine
plenty of oily
hello great
what is this big oil
big big oil
a noisy bone
didn't like that at all uh
oh okay i see
so there's got to be some reason to be
up here right
okay so there's some reason to
be there right okay so i do need to
figure out a way to get this up
okay but it seemed to be stuck let me
see if there's a another way to go
down here to the left
there was something else i think this
might just loop back to that other one
that's
closed
oh hey hi
oh my god baby not the time
right now is not the time okay
all right good great why did i do that i
don't know i've i have no idea
i don't know why that was important baby
uh yeah what do you want
i just need to keep calm do you remember
what the doctor said
okay sure who's the papa
maybe you should think about that a
little more
right so there's got to be a way to get
it up because that's how i'm going to
hop it
over there i mean it doesn't look like
it's
oh that oh
it was hitting that thing that makes
more sense
okay so now that i got it unclogged i
should just be able to go in the other
one
yada yada oh not that high right
there which would perfectly yeah okay i
get it now
oh just man delicate machinery here
hey wait a minute hey
oh wow
i know how to do this oh you fools you
foolish fools you think that your
puzzles can thwart me they cannot
they cannot i'm going
i'm just gonna deal with the darkness
for now oh there's a lot of darkness
just gonna deal with it for a bit for a
bit i'm fine
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine this helps hey baby i like this
light mama
hey mama i like this lights blue and
alien and for some reason i'm
really appreciative of it you know
better than this human light that you
got
i mean our human light wink wink wink
wink wink
wink wink wink am i winking wink
wink wink perfect
anyway all right
and we're a genius i suppose we could
just jump down from there what our ribs
were
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] all right
well man they they should have built
like a ladder or something
really would have improved the decor
the feng shui if you will
and you probably won't
and i got four i got four i got four i
got all four
great stuff guys great stuff
this is great what am i saying oh yeah
it was just as bad as i imagined
well that's close now hey how you doing
bud
hey bob i'm feeling pretty hungry that
corpse ain't gonna do nothing for nobody
else
whoa that's creepy
i'll save it a little bit i got some oil
so might as well stock up on
some of these first oh
it's fine it's nothing
sure a lot of bones
excuse me it's like going through snow
i'm sorry you prepared me expecting
mother coming through
whoa uh okay um all right wait hang on
let's
let's talk about this for a second okay
let's talk about houdini's box here
for a moment let's talk about houdini's
uh
closet going on air
i thought there was gonna be more um
is anything going to explain what's
going on here did
anyone want to talk to me about this
thing everybody want to
explain what the hell this is all about
sorry
how about film mom mom i got a bad
feeling about this i feel like there's
monsters everywhere and they want to
kill you
got a bad feeling about it real bad real
bad feeling
i'm almost out of oil okay
i think i just got to stop using my
lantern so much i'm there's no way that
i'm going to be able to keep enough oil
never mind never mind
there's nothing in these boxes oh is
that another houdini box
wow that's strange okay sure let's go
oh no why did i smash
oh please i'm down here now it's fine
[Applause]
oh no oh no no no no no no no no no
baby's angry baby's angry
i don't know
oh
[Music]
what the hell
what the hell what's happened
i don't know what has happened
i don't know what has happened oh i'm in
a hole i'm in one of the holes
oh i'm in one of the holes
it seemed like uh i was grunting and
growling quite a bit there
well that's a bit of a jump can i make
it through excuse me this
rib cage is in my way hey i better you
okay where am i now
i'm okay i'm pretty close to where i was
oh that's fascinating
that's so strange so it must be some
kind of
affliction i'm not going to go with
infection just yet
all right well wait a second oh my god
oh my god oh my god
how am i supposed to be able to hide if
suddenly i go crazy
what do i do what do i do oh my god i'm
hiding
oh
i guess they're not gonna go away so i
think i gotta go around them
oh he was hobbling
oh my god oh my god no
please no i didn't want any i didn't do
it it wasn't me
where am i oh my god wall okay and
hiding
perfect perfectly executed
they'll never know
i'll never know
oh my god oh my god oh my god where is
it where is it i don't know i don't know
i'm just gonna go for
oh it god hey how are you doing okay my
mistake
my bad hey excuse me okay i just i can't
go anywhere near you're just gonna slap
me around
okay that's really rude i'm pregnant so
you shouldn't do anything about that hey
don't mess with my mama i'm the baby now
talking
okay hey whoopee dee doo this is not
gonna help it's not gonna help is it not
gonna help
go over there
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy it's
fine it's fine it's fine
i got this all planned out all planned
out
easy peasy easy peasy easy my p my
pieces are easy
i've got so many pieces and boy are they
easy
oh my god there's another oh there's
another oh
where do i go where do we go oh my god
where do i go i don't know where i'm
going i'm going to hide now
shhh
no no don't make noise stupid bones
yeah man may look bad
okay
oh no go over there oh what am i doing
whoa hey hey
i don't know where to go where do i go
through this little hole no it can't be
it's got to be the little hole is it a
little oh it's a little hole it was a
little hole the whole time it was the
light guiding me but i was like i didn't
see your way through it so i didn't go
in there like an
idiot how you doing baby
i'm good man i'm good
i'm good sing me a lullaby hush little
baby
don't be alien
that's handle all by
good stuff good stuff
really good oh no
well seems like we're now into the game
proper
with all the spooks and the monsters so
that's good they kind of remind me of
like necromorphs anyone else seeing that
like a little bit of a i only got like
glimpses of it obviously but i was
feeling a little bit necromorph oh do i
gotta go for a swim
am i about to go i'm about to go for a
swim aren't i sploosh
i hate it hate it oh yeah i know baby
baby listen mom did you know you
couldn't breathe
weird okay you know what
uh i'll settle down now i'm gonna take a
nap
okay and carrying on
what does this do oh it's your bad
pipe it's bad pipe didn't mean to do
that that was a bad pipe
can't opener yeah okay thanks
thank you thank you
no
it better not
oh oh no okay it's not a water
my god boundary it up oh my god
i know i know i
okay i can see i'm open to close i fall
there where am i going
[Music]
i can't see it's all darkness
oh god
yeah you doing i know it's horrible
but together thanks mom
hey little one don't worry
you'll be okay uh-huh we'll be okay yeah
just like our just like your ribs
just like your ribs ma oh that fell when
did that fall
oh it felt before that's right i
remember okay cool
yeah i was um that was an experience
that was uh that was something else
really some else ma
i tell you what oh something else
is this a dead end oh no what
who are you what do you want
uh oh
perfect yeah this is what i'm looking
for
oh this don't seem good what is this
oh my god oh my god i can't oh
well done precious one
okay good memories good memories great
memories actually
it's kind of like being born all over
again
yeah to break more bones your spine was
shattered in half mom but i had some
knitting needles in here so i just sewed
them right back
up everything's kind of blurry can't see
do you need me to fix your eyes
i can do it from the inside here oh you
worry
ouch
just let me know you're all right
are you there little one
you're okay aren't you just
just sleeping
okay all right
well i'm pretty sure it was the bashing
of the water against the walls that did
it
who are you what do you want are you the
alien papa
look what you did to me where you put
inside me how dare you
tell me maybe who knows at this point
anything could be true
um i know this is probably all poop
water that i'm waiting through
oh wait you came this way
not good not at all
we may be chad but he will not
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um yeah uh we went through the
the water sploosh we did that we did
that we did that
did we do that are you sure about that
that are you sure
so all those gates were closed and i had
to open them up again
the thing in the fort a ghoul you said
what was it i i don't know
it's just a story it said they wanted
grace
oh was there more to that i don't know
hey this looks like it might be a hole
in the wall hole in the universe
universal hole do i not have the magic
toxin anymore because my baby's dead
is that the problem hey baby maybe
you're there
is that actually a thing i feel like
that actually is a thing
well oh
yeah that's fine alive
christ almighty don't go near it tazzy
i think i think she's trying to help us
oh my god oh my god oh my god my god
it's a [ __ ] devil he's what it is
oh so you saw this thing too okay that's
that's great
that's good stuff um there you go is
that what i was supposed to do
doinkus sure
1937. i am tazzy trianan
i survived the crash of the plane
cassandra
with me are hank mitchell yasmin shabani
dr anton mezier leon de frise
and malik tambora my husband salim and
others
are in a cave near the crash and need
help
some have died richard fairchild could
not handle what we saw here
he ran alex sterling has gone after him
we can't wait we must do something that
is
utter insanity hank mitchell
our leader and my friend was badly
wounded by a creature in the fort
yasmin calls it a ghoul
a flesh eating monster from desert
legends
she may be right hank is losing blood
fast
and he will die there is no time to get
to hell
there is a shrine here to a local spirit
this will sound like madness
she appeared to us
a figure of glowing light she spoke to
us she offered
healing and to save us from the desert
and i
i agreed she led us to an amulet
hidden here in the shrine i took it
now there is a a shimmering doorway
in the rock i swear it wasn't there
before
if we step through hank might survive
he is so pale ah salim i don't know what
else to do this is crazy
but i promise i promise
i will return to you
why is the handwriting going all crazy
and why is there blood on it that's
that's what's
strange i mean there's many things
strange about that letter there's
many many things especially the content
they're in
so i'm sorry was that a radio i have a
radio
yes yes i'm here doctor oh it's so good
to hear your voice
ah you're still
well where are you the oasis
oh we were here before what happened to
us
i just read something
i wrote there's a spirit
a glowing spirit i've seen her i will
explain it all darcy come to the village
we have lit a beacon in the tower look
for the smoke
thank you thank you doctor
you talked about my blackouts i have
these marks
on my skin and i keep losing
control you gave me a medicine
what's wrong with me
i do not know for certain we need
diagnostic implements reference books
civilization remember tassie control
yourself
avoid fear avoid anger at all costs
i have to go yes man she needs me doctor
doctor hey i need you
i need you doctor okay so something
obviously
ain't too right with me there's the
smoke
that's pretty far away
well time to hit the old dusty trail
it looks pretty far i don't know what
you mean little one
a village people a way home
yes um you love paris
we'll go walking in the luxembourg
gardens uh-huh
i'm sure yeah
[Music]
hi birdy how you doing birdy
hey birdy hey when we get to the village
you can meet the doctor oh that sounds
great yes
she's from angel she's nice i don't know
where algier is
she'll figure out what's wrong with me
all will be
will be well uh-huh oh we'll be well
just like all is well
all is swell actually
real swell this is all of it actually
oh boy here we go
oh no yeah me neither
all right
oh no
yeah but what if i don't yeah but what
if i don't yeah but what if i don't yeah
but what if i don't
what if i just don't
ah screw it i'm going in hello
hey oh
thank you glad that was there
really convenient okay
cool oh no quicksand
[ __ ]
well
doc i guess i'll catch you later
christ we were so close yeah that's how
games go the hell is this place now
i don't know boop
boop beep okay so we fell down in a hole
hey hey how you doing okay we fell down
in a nice hole
there's a butthole on the ceiling but
it's an alien butthole so
that's fine so i'm gonna end this one
here i'm enjoying this this
this part really like uh felt oh
this part definitely felt more true to
uh amnesia and definitely had like it
took a while to get into it but now
i'm getting into it and i'm enjoying it
quite a bit so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below
expect more of these coming regularly
and as always i will see you in the next
video bye-bye